(birds chirping)
- Valor is fifth through seventh grade
at two different middle
schools on the same campus.
Our kids are at the
highest academic scores
in the state, top 1% for
growth and achievement.
We think really strong SEL
work is very advantageous
to kids also doing well
academically in school.
- [Teacher] Everyone figure this out.
- Scholars, in order to really
learn, they have to be vulnerable.
By developing really strong SEL practices
with our scholars we build a lot of trust
and so they're much more
likely and get their hand up
or they go to their peers and ask for help
because they feel comfortable being okay
that they don't know everything.
So that's been one of the most
tangible things that we've seen.
- Some of the core elements
that we have here at Valor
came directly out of my work at Seneca.
- Daren was working at Seneca Center,
which is a non-profit that works
with some of the most disadvantaged youth
in the Bay area and he developed
a process called circle
with them over many years.
I went to visit once and saw the
social emotional learning development
that he's doing with these kids
and it really blew my mind.
- And that's what sparked
the ah ha of starting Valor.
Thinking about could we
take some of those practices
that push and develop all of us to grow
and make it a centerpiece
of a public school.
- So we are the first school
in the state of Tennessee
to open an intentionally diverse school.
- [Todd] We target about
50% free and reduced lunch.
We also don't have any majority
race or ethnicity in this school.
- We believe that for
our kids to be successful
we need to learn with and from
people that are different.
- I've been incredibly
inspired about the importance
of helping people reach
across the lines of
difference and adapt
diversity of perspective.
We wanna hear people
have different opinions
'cause that's actually
what makes us stronger.
So I think an intentionally
diverse community
creates a really powerful
opportunity for that year.
- Pride groups are single gender
groups of about 20 or so students.
Led by their pride leader
and their mentor teacher.
- It's comparable to, I
guess, an advisory group
in some schools, they
meet in the mornings.
We're kind of the closest
family unit in the school
and we do a lot of our
character work with them.
My expectations for you are that you are
working on your Phase packet.
(students talking)
- Through our pride
groups we do Phase work
that develops sharp mind, big hearts,
noble purpose, and aligned actions.
Each phase has activities that
align to those character strengths.
And so in the packets there's
reflections, and guided questions.
They're working on things like challenges,
they work on community service,
they do interviews with each other.
So, it's really an opportunity for them
to connect in multiple
ways with multiple people.
- It's just asking me my stories.
I had to do a 60 day challenge and we did
10 anonymous acts of
kindness toward someone.
- Think about who you
want to do that with.
- Without Phase work I probably wouldn't
be thinking about those things very much.
- [Teacher] Has it been easy for you
to answer these questions?
- No.
- Girls are still getting
to know themselves
and aren't really sure how to approach
work that's so introspective.
Like, What are my personal values?
You only have to put as much on the
page as you feel comfortable. Okay?
And so, we need to be
making sure that they feel
successful and confident
in what they're working on.
- Do you feel like you got
better at it as you went?
- Yeah, I definitely got better.
- Okay.
- Phase work helps you meet your goals
and it helps you form relationship
with other people from
different religions, race.
Helps you know them better in
ways you probably never would.
Yeah, that sounds good.
- [Matt] That kind of questioning,
that kind of reflection
is what helps us become
more well rounded and
realize that we have to continue to grow.
(people talking)
- [Daren] It all kinda culminates in
the circle practice that we do.
(people talking)
Our circle model is something
that both our adults
and our scholars do
every week for an hour.
Circles are a time for the community to
come together and develop themselves as
individuals, develop their relationships.
Is there more you need to talk about?
Circle is done in a ritualistic and
kind of structured manor.
Every circle would follow
the same basic cadence.
- All right, we're going to
start by doing our true north.
- [Daren] It'll always start with
a mindfulness based practice.
- Start by taking one,
silent, deep breath in.
And then, slowly letting it out.
- It's an invitation for everybody
to let go of the busy day and really
focus their attention on each other.
- [Matt] We are going to
do a weather check-in.
- [Daren] Then it moves into a check-in.
- I feel sunny because it's Friday.
- [Daren] It's helpful for
a community to hear where
everybody is, and know the
emotional tone of the group.
And then we move into what we call work.
- [Matt] So, Eric, are you
ready to do your presentation?
- The topic I investigated was religion.
- [Daren] They will present their Phase
work as part of their circle work.
- [Eric] We're supposed to research and
write three opposing opinions on the topic
and three supporting opinions.
This experience helped me
learn that I can be kinder
to people with different perspectives.
- Circle is a space
that's safe enough that
they get to share who they
are, what they dream about,
what their cultures are like,
what they're frustrated by.
It also builds relationships
that help us become
better teachers, help them
become better learners.
- Whether it be somebody
telling about hardships
they've been through
or somebody who's going
through things right
now and needs support.
I've seen girls grow in circle, and
I've seen girls help each other grow.
- [Teacher and Students] Be good,
do good, stay fierce and keep roaring.
(student roaring)
- I think having the adults do the
practice themselves and really know the
importance of it is our main strategy.
Adults drive this type
of work in the community.
- [Woman] Steven would
you mind kicking us off?
- Some work that I've done with kids in
this past week that I
need to bring to circle.
In circle today I did a process
called taking responsibility.
Which is used for repairing a relationship
with the community as a whole.
Moving forward I commit
to like, using the systems
that are in place and thinking
before I act in such a way.
I ask kids to do it every day.
And I think that's why Valor works.
It's because like everything
the kids are asked to do,
the adults are expected to do as well.
- It helps a lot because they also
know what we're going through.
Other schools can say,
like, you don't understand
to your teachers, but
like, we can't say that
because they do the same thing as us,
and they know what we're going through.
- [Daren] You guys did a really good job.
Appreciate yourselves for that.
Kids will succeed more
academically because
they feel safe and they're
in trusting relationships.
And they feel inspired and have a purpose.
- [Student] I appreciate you being kind
to me and all of our scholars.
Thanks.